[music]
goo
[music] What the hell is
making you go that far
?  But
when I think about it, infinite power naturally springs up from the bottom of my body.
Mao The
long battle is finally over
[music]
voodoo
goo I
wanted to be a wizard of justice yeah yeah yeah
This city was born and developed together with Arzaa's Imperial Academy of Magic.  It is
because of the presence of the Imperial Academy of Magic, which has been in business for over 400 years, that it became famous as a
magician.  It's prohibited to use it, so please
keep it a secret.
Of course, thank you.
Also, all of the famous magicians are from this academy,
but when I
went to Harumi, they would have gone ahead of me.
Stop it,
when we were a family
Gum Sisty Yeah, yeah
[music]
But it's
rare for City to forget something Maybe I'll buy it with that girl Day 9th teacher
Why did you suddenly quit?  It's good to
have someone as enthusiastic as the ninth-ranked teacher.
[music] You're
thin, do
n't hurt yourself, you'll be fine. You jumped
out suddenly,
but it's dangerous.  I'm
sorry, I'm
sorry.
Even if I knit it,
ah,
4 days, 3 days, tano, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, I can't
believe you touched a girl so bluntly.  You're going to
give an unknown
man a job as a lecturer at this academy, albeit a part-
time one.  I wonder if
something happened, let alone the students, but the instructors at this academy, it's not unheard of in the past.
Or take that, and
you've
hit the jackpot, huh?
I'm
Guren Raiders, and I'll be here to help you with your studies for the next month.
If you don't like it, you won't have any problems with your magical power capacity and memory.
At least the 4th heat will be 5 vs 6,
but can he tell the excellent students at our school that it's
impossible
?  And
he's a Lancer with a teaching license.
One day, when I was 15, I thought I would finish my degree quickly, and then I would
die after 4 years.
Do you believe in that witch?  I
wonder if it's okay to say Haru.
Forcibly screwing a magician with no track record into crimson Alex
's reaction is normal I'll take responsibility Now, I'll take responsibility for everything he does at this academy
So far,
what is he to you?  I do
n't have any special stories or special innerwear.I
just
did
n't want him to be profitable.  Even
after taking Tekken, it seems like you still don't feel like taking classes seriously.
However, I don't really understand the translation into the common language, so I don't
understand ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ahhh please
wait for me
If you can't answer King Jeongjo's question, I think it's your duty as a lecturer to find out the answer before the next class.  It
wasn't a problem By any
chance, you haven't yet learned how to look up a dictionary.
Revision Let's lower the motivation Well well The
next alchemy experiment signal will oversee, right?  The
future of the city is white, beautiful and finely detailed 1
can
something like Jujo 3 I'm growing up Hey, why am I here
?
There's a need.
No matter how you think about it,
I'm going to
open my scorched eyes.  I
know how Hyōe City feels, but let's have a good time eating.
Even though I have to,
ah ah ah
Four turnips
moon ah ah ah That
teacher eats a lot
Do you like to eat?  It
seems like it's because it's the season for Rome, so
I'll try it
next time.  The
mulberry branch and the statue outside It's just that I don't eat much because I get sleepy in the afternoon class.
Then why don't you say it
clearly?  I was
also doing grass
a
[music],
but is it a short trip? It's the
Stars and Stripes, but I'm a
part-time teacher at the Academy of Magic Until a new one comes,
why don't you do it?  You don't have a teacher's license.
Stop it.
Then I'll put it in ice.  I
don't want to say too much, but I don't want to say too much, but
I'm the daughter of a family who finally has a certain amount of influence.  You can make a new decision on whether to advance or retreat.I
don't really want to resort to this kind of method in writing, but if you say you won't change your attitude toward protests, please
tell your father that you have high expectations.
Or I was in a mode of being stopped and
I reluctantly tried to accept it, but it was impossible.  But I
want you to change your attitude so far and take the class seriously.
Think about it,
then,
as the next head of the Fibel family, I
ca
n't overlook someone like you who despises magic.
Hey, I'll
take that ticket It seems like it's old The
duel between a student and a lecturer is unheard of
It must be too interesting
[music]
Shock Bolton is the only method other than that is prohibited. The
rule of color lineage has recipients and has the right to decide.  I
don't know what that means.
Shock bolt is certainly a general-
purpose magic.  The
spell is coming to the planet The shock of the streetcar is also the steel
Shoot down the 3 verses
But in practice, the victory or defeat is determined by how quickly you can catch the chanting in a theory that omits the 3rd verse.  You know,
even if it's a bone or a professor's endorsed magician,
leaves aren't a good face, are
n't they?  As long as
I'm me, I can't let such a man go unchecked
Even if it means licking Bhutan's day
a
[music]
yes haha ​​that
eh a eh it's a
mistake I'll
give you at least one flower  I'm not
saying that because it's about time to
win the order, so the treasure
can't be baited
by Yadaya.  It's
okay, but there won't be a next time.  It's
like a soy sauce house, and the condition was bad.
Hey Na Na
Monokai 6 Poetry of Life Witch Sports and Akask Records Final Episode
Guren Seisei-san's
Class Just Thank You for Watching